You got good morals.
What's good morals?
You know what
good morals is, bruv.
It means you'll always
be there for your family…
and for your brothers.
And you'll never
let them down.
In this season of Top Boy,
many of the characters
are walking tightropes,
both outside and at home.
While some appear calm
on the surface,
internally they're at war,
living lives
of quiet desperation.
They are wrestling with
their own sense of morality
in a lifestyle
and a wider society
where empathy can cost
and even kill.
Amid these tensions
and their long,
intense days,
they try to find
their way through.
My name is Aniefiok
"Neef" Ekpoudom,
and in this video,
we'll be exploring
right and wrong in Top Boy.
In the early half
of the season,
we're reunited with Sully.
He's at war with himself.
After the traumas of seeing
Jason burn to death
in the previous season,
we find him
as he is distancing himself
from the roads.
He moves into a barge
on the Thames,
slowly attempting to pull
his life back together,
piece by piece,
but those years
still haunt him.
Fuck! Hey!
-You're fucking early.
-My bad, bro.
He is seeking to recover
from the hangover of a life
where he lived on the edge
for so long.
But as Sully
peels back the layers
and tries to find space
to recover,
he is forced to confront
his past actions.
The guilt of murdering Dris
is eating at him
from the inside.
You done Dris, didn't you?
Come on.
Don't know what the fuck
you're talking about.
Don't lie to me, man.
You killed him.
Tell me you didn't kill him.
Look me in my eyes
and tell me
that you didn't do it.
Dris was my friend.
That's not denying it,
is it?
He scrambles to try
and make things right,
easing the guilt he feels
by offering Mandy,
Dris's girlfriend, money.
My life is different now.
I don't want this.
It's a cruel lesson:
our actions can define us,
the world may always see you
as who you once were,
no matter how far
you try and outrun it.
And so he must sit
with the consequences
of who he used to be.
It's not a situation
unique to Sully.
Throughout the season,
we find many of the youngers
wrestling with
their own morality.
Either through home traumas
or life on the roads,
they have suffered
and they're trying
to survive the day
the best way they know how.
Cracks only appear
when they are confronted
by other members
of the community.
I know what you make him do.
You use him in the streets.
I know.
I don't make him do nothing.
I don't know what
you're talking about, man.
Jamie has an awareness
of that desperation,
and it allows him
to show sympathy
for the decisions Ats made.
He recognises the vice
Ats was locked in,
even if that vice cost Jamie
his own freedom
and tore him
from his family.
He used to come here
and spend time with us,
like watch TV with us,
eat with us, bro,
stay with Stef.
You used to help Stef
with homework,
help him with shit
that I couldn't, bro.
So I'll be real, like…
I'm not even trying
to hear that.
Whatever he did…
what Dushane made him do…
the youth was family.
Family is Jamie's
guiding light,
his North Star.
Everything he risks
is for them.
And in their situation,
where he is relied on
as the primary provider,
any idea of what is
considered right or wrong
pales in significance
when the stakes
are Stef and Aaron.
I didn't ask for this…
to be the mum and dad
to you and Stef.
Fam, it's hard.
Proper hard, bro.
Man, for all of us.
I know you've been tryin',
and I've been tryin'.
But I need you to know,
Aaron, yeah?
Everything that I do…
and all that I care about
is the two of you.
You and Stef,
that's it.
Ats was a foreshadowing,
and before long
the same desperation
that plagued Ats
eventually confronts
Jamie too.
He finds himself in a vice,
either kill
his best friend Kit
or uproot his siblings
and flee to Cardiff,
costing Aaron his degree
and Stef
any sense of stability.
-He keeps true to mantra…
-Bro!
…prioritising family
over anything
and everything.
Hauntingly, that decision
to look out for his siblings
over himself
ultimately costs him
his life.
Jamie! Jamie!
Jamie shows
that there is more here
than the individual.
Our actions never exist
in isolation or a vacuum.
We are all products
of an environment,
moulded by our surroundings.
In Top Boy,
a coldness is threaded
through the city
they inhabit,
flowing from the top
downwards.
This youth.
One of ours.
He got shanked up bad.
Fourteen years old.
Someone shanked
the life out of him,
left him in a fucking skip.
You believe that?
Like he meant nothing.
First we see Amma,
Ats's mother,
forced to leave the country
while still grieving
for her murdered son.
She's lived in this country
for 19 years.
She's worked legally
right up until you people
stopped her.
She's paid her taxes,
she has rights.
This woman has just lost
her one and only son
to a devastating
knife crime.
Are you aware of that?
Is that in your file?
Can't you see this is wrong?
Elsewhere, Summerhouse is
undergoing massive change.
East London
is rapidly gentrifying.
The tower blocks
are coming down
and the residents
are being moved out.
The looming forces
of the council
and the private developers
are squeezing out
the local community,
tearing families
from their homes.
Residents are rehoused
in far-flung places
like Bolton and Croydon.
And in an attempt to seize
the remaining properties,
the developers
make life hell
for the remaining residents.
The developers treat them
as mere afterthoughts,
minor obstructions
to the fruitful land
that they have been
living on for decades.
Basic needs
and any care
for human decency
is stripped away
as the developers ruthlessly
pursue the valuable land
that sits under Summerhouse.
I can't believe they're
making you guys still go.
Do they know about
your mum's treatment?
They know.
Just don't give a shit.
Nobody is more a product
of their environment
than Dushane.
He's grown up in Summerhouse
and has seen
powerful institutions
wielding the fate of
a community in their hands,
reaching out and grabbing
for whatever they wish.
And so he does the same,
deciding to go for what
he wants by any means.
Rather than trying to play
fair in an unfair world,
he adopts
their same behaviours.
His decision to link up
with the developers
ultimately sees his
relationship with his mum
come to a crisis point.
Want me to be honest?
I sell drugs.
'Cause people
wanna get high.
Everyone does it.
And all of them politicians
you watch on the news,
they all get high, you know.
That's life.
That's how it goes.
I mean, even the
Prime Minister was on TV
talking about how someone
gave him drugs.
Why ain't he in jail?
That man has no morals.
Don't try and use him
to justify what you do.
I know you're using
the money you've made
to tear down this community.
Empathy and compassion
are a tightrope.
And for a man like Sully,
still half in and half out,
we are shown
that love and understanding
can be dangerous.
Look, what it is,
Delphine, is…
where I've been…
people ain't really
that nice to you.
When his niece, Pebbles
gets in trouble
with a group from Peckham,
he feels himself slowly
being drawn back in.
Them men ain't gonna
give a fuck!
I know, I've been them!
They is gonna want
their shit back.
He starts to lose
who he was becoming,
filtering back
into old ways.
In confrontations,
he tries to show reason
and a level of empathy,
a new man in a world
that hasn't changed.
First with Rashaun…
-The fuck you doing?
-Pebbles!
You took something from her
that weren't hers to give,
but the people it belongs
to, they're fucking serious.
And she might not have told…
Look at me!
She might not have
told you that.
'Cause she's fucking
sideways, I know.
But I'm here being nice.
They come…
they ain't gonna be nice.
And then with the group
in South London.
After reason fails,
he has to resort
to violence.
What's wrong
with this silly boy?
What's the point
in all this?
I get it, you men are
fucking embarrassed.
Pride and that.
But neither work.
In the end,
trying to bargain
with the South London lot
and doing a favour
for Pebbles
almost costs him his life.
Love can get you killed.
The incident changes him.
He scrubs away the promise
of who he was becoming
and falls back
into his old self.
As the compassion
withers away,
a ruthlessness emerges
in its place,
and it culminates with him
murdering Jamie
in front of Stef.
It was a defining moment
for one of the most troubled
characters in the series.
The promise of what he
could have been is gone,
lost to the darkness.
Dushane is also changed
by a traumatic event.
His mum passes away
while he is out
on the roads.
Distraught by her death,
he almost collapses.
Eventually,
he heeds the words
of their final conversation
and steps in
to secure the future
of the community
in Summerhouse.
You gotta change the plans
back to the way they were.
Tell mum,
she used to say…
"Summerhouse is
more than numbers."
It's a subtle shifting
of the dial.
By the end of the season,
both him and Sully
have inched slightly away
from who they once were,
and Jamie has gone.
The season is an observation
of how young people caught
in desperate circumstances
wrestle with morality
and empathy,
sometimes to
their own detriment.
We are shown
that there are dangers
for doing the right thing,
but also freedom.
You do what you have to
to protect the people
that you love.
The people you care about,
your family.
And I love you for that.